(slogan en anglais)
- La grève n'aura finalement
duré que deux jours.
(slogan en anglais)AsAsAssez pos
de soutien se fassent entendre.
Et surtout, assez pour
faire monter la pression
sur le gouvernement Ford,
alors que les syndicats
faisaient planer la menace
d'une grève générale.
"Comme signe de bonne foi,
nous allons retirer
la loi spéciale à condition
qu'ils mettent fin à la grève",
a déclaré le premier ministre
Doug Ford.
Quelques heures plusd,d,d,
c'était au tour du syndicat
de célébrer sa victoire.
(acclamation)
Les 55 000 travailleurs
de soutien seront donc
de retour dans les écoles
dès demain matin.
Devant la législature
ontarienne, la nouvelle
est accueillie avec soulagement
pas s s grévistes.
- Si on a enlevé la loi,
il n'y a pas de problème,
nous allons rentrer à la table
s s s négociations avec
le gouvernement bien sûr.
"Je suis content, car je vais
pouvoir revoir mes amis",
sourit cet élève.
Mais le bras de fer est loin
d'être terminé et la question
salariale continue de diviser
les deux parties.
"Je dois agir de manière
responsable avec l'argent
des contribuables", a martelé
Doug Ford.
Les syndiquéuxuxux, promettent
de négocier de bonne foi, mais
n'hésiteront pas à débrayer
à nouveau en cas d'impasse.
En reculanr r r sa loi
spéciale, le gouvernement Ford
renonce aussi à invoquer
la disposition de dérogation de
la Charte canadienne des droits
et ltététés. Le premier ministre
ontarien a toutefois refusé
de promettre qu'il n'utiliserait
pas cet outil exceptionnel dans
de futurs conflits de travail.
i i i qui s'était pourtant
fait élire en se décrivant
comme l'ami des syndicats.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Tor